I'm so glad to be sitting here with you
right now first of all love the denim
that you're wearing right now very
important denim I'm so glad there's
finally a line with a massive range of
sizes fitting different curves and shape
it's me for the real woman it is I like
to think that it is for sure and you
know good American was something that
was strategically planned in that way
because there really was it's not that
we needed another denim company it was
more that we needed a denim company that
actually fit real woman yes and so
that's really how good American was
created but this is more than just a
fashion line it's a passion project for
you I mean I understand it kind of
reflects from your own experiences when
you went shopping and and with their
friends as well yeah what I used to be
bigger and I was a size between a 12 to
a 16 at one point and which to me isn't
anything astronomical but in you know
Beverly Hills okay very how dare you be
a like in the double digits and I used
to shop with my sisters or my
girlfriends and I would be ushered into
literally another floor almost an attic
somewhere and it would be mortifying and
uncomfortable and there would be such
limited pieces for me to choose from and
when I had the opportunity to do good
American and put my name on something
like this I said you know what if we do
this I want every single piece to have
the full size range I want women to
choose what their style is if you're
bigger if you're smaller if you're tall
petite whatever it's our choice to say
what our style is it's not for a brand
to say okay here's these four pieces in
a double XL so that's how you're gonna
choose from now how has the response
been from women since you've launched
the product it's been incredible it's
been something that people feel that
even if they're like maybe weary at
first about something the product speaks
for itself and even if you don't want to
get it because it's me or don't want to
get it because you think oh I have too
much denim or whatever once you try it
you realize wow the quality is
impeccable everything fits the great has
great recovery factor and it's a brand
that we could stand behind everything
that we say and that makes me feel good
I don't want to put something out there
that's not
going to in today's world where everyone
has a platform yeah that's not gonna
stand that platform and so it makes me
feel really good that it makes people
feel good about themselves and feel sexy
and confident and that their clothes are
made to fit them and they're not made to
fit the clothes that's that's perfect
that is so perfect that's exactly what
women need right now you also have a
maternity line yes that's something you
thought about while you were pregnant I
would love to have that when I was
pregnant but was that part of the plan
for you it was and we were creating it
during my pregnancy so I didn't get to
really fully enjoy the vast variety that
we have because we were in the middle
said gosh we got to do this and me and
my partner Emma she's had two
pregnancies so it was something that we
both I didn't know that there was a gap
in the market for that until I became
pregnant so selfishly we started
creating it during that time so the
denim came out during the end of my
pregnancy but I didn't get to really
enjoy the rest but I will say that the
pregnancy workout stuff I started
wearing after I gave birth because I was
at and in between size and I felt really
comfortable with the higher waistband
and your tummy is so weird after a baby
it takes the longest time to get reduced
or human it's true ages other problems
so why the name good American well it
was just something that we thought was
really catchy and we really just thought
that it was something that we could all
stand behind and there would be
longevity from it and we just thought it
was a really great universal name
obviously we try to do as much as we can
in America that doesn't mean everything
we can but we really try to do as much
in the United States as possible I love
that and you thought it to Canada and we
brought it to Canada it's so great to
talk to you about this and I can't wait
for the product for everyone to try it
again and I have a feeling a lot of them
will be wearing your denim I hope
you